An individual must be respected,
regardless of their religion, colour, gender
or where they are from.
By taking us captive,
Islamic State wanted to strip us of our honour.
ISIS wanted to break our will to live.
They took my mother,
who believed in the core values of humanity,
captive along with 86 Yazidi women in Soulagh.
ISIS killed them all because they did not want to be sex slaves.
Today, my community is falling apart because of brutal genocide.
Half a million people are uncertain about their future: Where can they go?
We must fight terrorism and we must cut it off at the source.
We must also fight extremism and racism,
which have become such dangers today.
An international accountability system
and a local counterpart must be set up to bring justice.
You decided to stand by Yazidi women
and the Yazidi community against genocide.
We look up to Europe as a symbol of humanity.
Europe should remain a model for the entire world
and a model for the coexistence of peoples and their cultures.
I say to ISIS, and all terrorists in the world,
if you have chosen the path of no dignity,
Europe has chosen for itself the path of humanity and honour.
Thank you.